it is martin luther king jr day and on
this martin luther king jr day we have a
special edition of our partnership with
ted ideas that matter
when author anna malaika tubbs visited
the mlk birthplace in atlanta there was
something that stuck with her i left
feeling frustrated by the tour guide
script
of course mlk junior was the center of
most of the tales
and then came stories about his father
the inspiring reverend martin luther
king senior
but what frustrated me was the lack of
attention being paid to his mother
alberta christine williams king
that visit helped inform tubbs book the
three mothers how the mothers of martin
luther king jr malcolm x and james
baldwin shaped a nation tubbs visited
the dr martin luther king jr memorial
tree grove in los angeles with her own
two children and offers this essay in
honor of his mother alberta
[Music]
today i celebrate the legacy of a
freedom fighter
a leader of the ever famous ebenezer
baptist church
a person who believed that faith must
always be intertwined with social
justice
that if you were to call yourself a
religious leader
you must also stand against oppression
poverty and discrimination
this person fought such inequities
through organizing and participating in
marches and boycotts
they were an active member of the end of
naacp
passionate about using their education
as a tool to combat racism and
inequality at large
her name was alberta christine williams
king
she was everything i've already
described as well as a talented musician
and a mother of three
by celebrating her on the day she
birthed her son in a room on the second
floor of their home
i also celebrate all the mothers who
deserve their long overdue recognition
isn't it amazing how much more we
understand martin when we also get to
know the woman who birthed and raised
him
isn't it beautiful to see how she
applied her passions and identity to her
mothering and how her son then took her
lessons and shared them with the world
leading the march the reverend martin
luther king isn't it powerful to see
martin not as some single disconnected
entity
but instead as a son
who was grateful to follow in his
mother's footsteps we still advocate
non-violence a passive resistance and
still
determine to use the weapon of love
proud to build on what he learned as a
little boy sitting at the table where he
not only enjoyed alberta's delicious
meals or listened to her sing gospel as
she cooked
but also where he heard his parents
discuss the importance of voting rights
and of helping meet the basic needs of
their church members i have a dream
privileges such as coming from a family
that was well educated and connected did
not always protect a young mlk junior
from the harsh realities of jim crow
he witnessed his family being
disrespected by store owners being
harassed by officers
he felt the pain of not being allowed to
see his friends once they came of an age
where it was no longer acceptable for
blacks and whites to mingle
like most of us do when we're faced with
the ugliness of the world
when we're scared or confused
martin sought his mother's comfort and
wisdom
alberta would hold him tightly
and tell him he was as good as anybody
as worthy of dignity and respect as
everyone else
she passed on her own strategies for
addressing injustice
she encouraged him to keep his faith
to find love
and to pursue his dreams
because she knew how revolutionary such
happiness and persistence were in the
face of such hatred
when we celebrate martin
we must also celebrate alberta
we must know her story
and learn how she not only shaped her
children
but also how she shaped our entire
nation
when we do this
we also recognize the essential roles
our mothers are playing not only in
their own homes but in our society
through honoring alberta we honor the
many acts of mothering
we honor the wisdom of mothers we honor
their leadership
we honor their comfort
we honor their love
may we all think of both martin and
alberta as we think about how far we
have come
and how far we have left to go
as we come together to make this world
more inclusive
as we fight the forces that try to rob
human beings of the dignity respect and
recognition we all deserve
may we think of them both
happy king day
what a smart day indeed beautiful it was
smart what a smart and different way to
very well
really beautifully done very well done
the power of love and belief in your
children
what it can reap and the difference that
a mother can make but i like what you
said tony what a different way to honor
him on this day and i kudos to animal
ikebs who by the way is married to
michael tubbs a former mayor of stockton
clearly they have two beautiful children
a nice nice couple but i've never seen
it i've never seen his story told that
way and that's to me what makes it so
very now that you mention it i knew of
his father i had heard of it i had never
heard of his mom and that was an
injustice in its own right beautiful
tribute to both